[Música]
a los 7 años a los 7 años me dijeron que
no podría bailar flamenco
me operaron de un riñón el médico me
dijo no podrás zapatear
a mí me da igual yo sabía que iba a
bailar
poco a poco la cosa se fue complicando
empecé a perder mi naturalidad todo lo
que me rodeaba
no me lo ponía fácil
el no ser masculino de bailar daba pie a
que yo fuera diferente y eso a mis
compañeros del colegio no les gustaba
sufrí bullying durante muchos años
en ese momento yo quería tener éxito
para mostrar que era válido
empecé a bailar muy joven con gente
mucho más mayor que yo con una
experiencia impecable en la que cada día
me recordaba cómo debería ser un gran
bailarín
yo no estaba de acuerdo pero parecía ser
el único camino para poder llegar a mi
sueño
yo no conocía a otro
estaba confuso empezaba a creer que
bailar estaba relacionado con sufrir
me trasladé a la escuela más grande de
flamengo mi familia no entendía lo que
iba
pero yo tenía mucha fuerza ilusión y
poco dinero
me fui solo a la aventura en busca de
esa idea que tenía sobre el éxito
estuve diez años estudiando trabajando
en grandes compañías con grandes
coreógrafos y pasar de trabajar de salas
de fiestas a grandes teatros
pero no sentía ese éxito esperado
me enseñaron a mover mi cuerpo y a tapar
mi interior cogiendo unos patrones que
se alejaban de lo que ya yo
esto no me desanimo simplemente no
encajaba en la forma de entenderlo
calidad
de esta manera otra vez decidí abandonar
y buscar otra fórmula a la que me
sintiera cómodo y libre
a veces tenía miedo pero sabía que
buscar y cambiar era mi salida
empecé a estudiar cosas que según me
decían cuando era joven no estaban
relacionadas con lo que hacía y de esta
manera empecé a abandonar esa persona
que creía que era y empecé a ver esa
persona que realmente era
me di cuenta que no era ni bueno ni malo
me di cuenta que ese éxito que buscaba
jamás iba a llegar porque simplemente no
era yo
y poco a poco vi esa idea que tenía
sobre el éxito como que ya no me
importaba tanto
empecé a bailar sin ninguna pretensión
solo hacía y veía lo que pasaba
comencé a aplicar mi presión a la
localidad y de esa manera me tiré la
nada salí a moverme entero y libre
fue entonces cuando tuve unas vivencias
increíbles que jamás antes puede
permitirme tener porque estaba muy
ocupado en sobrevivir
encontré en el esfuerzo la satisfacción
cada pequeño cambio que hago en mi vida
es un éxito ahora soy consciente de ello
porque por fin encontrado el significado
de la palabra éxito
escuchar ni verme por dentro es un éxito
afectarme y darme la oportunidad de
cambiar es todo un éxito
para mí bailar cuando era pequeño era
desaparecer de todos los problemas que
tenían pero con el tiempo esto se me
olvidó
intentando construir un bailarín
perfecto alejándome de lo que era yo
ahora me da igual que me cuestionen que
me digan que no soy bailarín de español
o que no bailo flamengo
lo que tengo claro es que no voy a
volver a ser esa persona que no era
estoy muy agradecido a todo lo que me ha
pasado y ya todo lo que me han enseñado
porque este proceso ha permitido ser
quien soy
buscamos el éxito en lo externo en forma
de poder o de reconocimiento
en experiencia el día que puede ver mis
necesidades aceptarlas y tener la fuerza
de cambiar por ellas mi vida cambió
radicalmente
[Aplausos]
sí
ah
[Aplausos]
y
i
[Aplausos]
y
ah
sí
[Aplausos]
e
ah
[Aplausos]
a